m
[Musique]
e
et
nous sommes à la poissonnerie de
cloridorme en haute gaspésie dans
quelques heures c'est pétoncles pêcher
dans les eaux du saint-laurent vont
prendre la route dans les épiceries du
québec au québec en une langue un seul
producteur puis
si son assemblée nationale berg au sort
aussi qui a très bon goût
jusqu'ici c'est pétanque était exporté
dans le monde entier mais deux
entrepreneurs gaspésien vienne changer
la donne
moi je montais toutefois son pour mes
amis à vis d'elle la figure de la
dernière fois raymond têtu porte mes
amis à vienne il avait monté pour 5000
dollars
vérifiez pas retrouvé les seuls poissons
que vous voyez quand on avait existé
la crevette clairement la saison
bon an mal an le canada exporte 80% de
sa production de poissons et fruits de
mer un marché lucratif pour ses produits
haut de gamme très recherchés en europe
et en asie j'ai commencé dès qu'un
comptoir 2 comtois trois cantons quatre
comptoirs est monté jusqu'à 7,8 comtois
puis ensuite je vais approcher des
livres qui vient d'enjoindre last
aventure le sait ce qu'est
il ya beaucoup de choses hein
professionnels marketing
des mises en marché
cogné aux portes passion dévorante et
quand même jusqu'à 130 voire les esprits
pour assurer perso
[Musique]
bajul morue pétoncles turbo crevettes
flétan ce congélateur contient 100 % de
poissons et fruits de mer d'ici
aujourd'hui on fait du personnage de
flatteur de l'atlantique c'est une prise
qui a été fracturé deux jours
[Musique]
pour réussir leur projet d'arrêt côté et
denis fortin ont dû tisser des liens
avec les pêcheurs et les transformateurs
de la gaspésie dont l'entreprise menut
maire
moi je prenais ce que c'est un très bon
coup d'oeil tout ce qui a des besoins
ces deux jeunes comme autant c'est
d'avoir quelqu'un pour les épauler pour
développer ces fameux produits du québec
on dirait que l'ensemble des producteurs
des usines vont y aller surtout au
niveau instruire et beaucoup expédie à
l'extérieur avec ledit et plein camion
toutes sortes de fromages du québec
c'est un peu des tout petits volumes
pour commencer mais dès qu'une de
commerce avec un produit qui est
intéressant pour satisfaire des
consommateurs qui donnant de plus en
plus des produits du québec qui au début
c'était potentiel le monde croyait pas
toutes au port est bien de fil en
aiguille réussi à acheter 20 ml bleus
n'était pas celle qu'on vient ce qui se
bat théo autour de nous au quai vert je
pense que ici on a la matière première
donc pourquoi pas d'en profiter aux pays
développés de porto rico jouaient ce
matin vous présenterez
finalement mis hors combat à la planche
sur des tumeurs en collaboration avec
l'entreprise les pêcheries gaspésiennes
dari et denis propose aussi des poissons
fumés en fait le fils de son volume à
chaud ça c'est le filet de morue ce fut
majeau on fait aussi l'audacieux
seulement au mois dé radio puis on ne le
filet de maquereau poids vous strange
fruits de mer du québec veut aussi
profiter de la popularité du
prêt-à-manger en proposant ses propres
plats cuisinés de la voix
c'est normal on va faire on va essayer
de tout ouvrir à mal de quesques
gaspésie et c'est ma bouffe pour
représenter nationale
et
pour offrir des prix compétitifs les
deux entrepreneurs misent sur la
collaboration avec les fournisseurs
pas question de partir en guerre contre
les gros exportateurs mais c'est de
conscientiser pour moussa a expliqué me
prouver le québécois puis sur les
sponsors et hic aucun niveau et ils vont
casser un vélib l'exportation
radi a déployé le poison qui veut sans
charme et maintenir des prix
raisonnables et répondre à la demande
toute l'année ce sont les deux défis de
fruits de mer du québec au québec
la page n'est pas l'année donc on va
travailler plus fort la saison seul est
des produits de côté pendant la haute
saison pour continuer à fournir aux
utilisateurs aux consommateurs en hiver
un produit qui est sûre jalil mais qui
de base excellente qualité
est ce que d'autres produits de la
gaspésie que vous voudriez faire
découvrir éventuellement le boulot qu'on
veut travailler que bordeaux on doit
travailler qu'entre telle vers la
gaspésie aussi dont la talonnade avoir
peut-être des quantités suffisantes
[Musique]
fruits de mer du québec prévoit
installer sous peu près de 300
congélateur dans l'ensemble des iga de
la province ainsi que dans des épiceries
indépendantes
[Musique]